how are you sir what's going on in your
life you good just sitting in Cleveland
every day you know they let a tough one
get away last night kids you know the
mood is real real somber here in these
parts so let me let me ask you what did
happen last night Cavs run out of gas
Warriors just asserted themselves to
what do you attribute that finale all
right I hear a lot of people are tired
of the tired because what rich is
supposed to be tired at the end of the
game you want to be able to put your
hand in the cold shower after window
loss and say I gave it all I got you
want to be exhausted when you're driving
all you want to be exhausted if not you
didn't exert the right amount of energy
so yeah they better ran out of gas but
you know a lot of things needed to
happen last night for them too wet you
know it's a lot of it's a lot of ifs
with that game if Kyle Korver would hit
the shot in the corner if LeBron
wouldn't miss two layups and win but I
could never blame that on fatigue
because at this point in the season if
you're not tired and you don't really
want that championship so what's missing
for the cats
was the last type that they may 11th f-1
get away I thought you know calico Cobra
when when he shot that one in the corner
I would have put him up five I thought
that I thought of you to hit that shot
it's been a different series different
attitude but hey you know the the
warrior shooters you know when they get
opportunity great shot that they don't
miss them no Kevin Durant when they were
down by I think too and he came down
shot that play put him up by one he
nailed the shot so all about making
shots is a make or miss league
Shaquille O'Neal joining us from
Cleveland let's get into it then because
you know this is going to be the
conversation let's front-load the
conversation if this is a sweep are the
Warriors the greatest team of all time
Shaquille O'Neal I would say that
they're us they're the first perfect
team and I'm but you know me I'm always
I'm always looking at the Celtics teams
and you know the Laker teams and uh you
know LeBrons team in Miami and if you
hard for me to say that they're the best
team ever
the record will indicate that they're
the best remixes they'll be the first
team to go 16 he'll win a championship
we almost didn't until obviously hit us
for that 55 in Game one that was
actually my goal to be the first team de
to do it but they already know surpassed
us uh so they asked you a question I
don't know yet so I think if they I
think if they win want to put put
together string of championships and you
can associate it but you're the best
treatment and then what's going to be
the league reaction will we see just as
many teams try to create super teams or
we going to see maybe a formation of a
bad boys type era where we're going to
start putting finesse or Elite of motion
type teams like the Warriors on their
ass what do you think I like you I think
you want to see more more more super two
teams you know a lot of people say
LeBron started it and you're Kevin Kevin
did it so you know we put we put so much
pressure on these great players to win
hey guys go do they go do to get the
ring way that's true and so then what
where's LeBron super team in Cleveland
or somewhere else with him making it a
super team you know that that you know
life you a lot of people speculate that
you know when Wendy way recruited him
and Chris Bosh yet that was the first
Super team and you know then you know
Kevin Durant did it too you know the
team that they will help 3-1 they lost
and then he joined them and you know he
has a lot of room to operate because you
know they have they have two guys on
that team that you must double and four
guys that you have to pay attention to
and they play great defense and they
have the decent player of the year and
draymond green and they move the ball
beautifully effectively and efficiently
and then I'll really care who gets the
most points or who's going who's on it
that's what makes our teams of did that
dream is super super soft so then like I
said to the Cavs try and get themselves
more people with Kyrie and LeBron best
they can slice it up salary cap wise or
does LeBron just basically say I'm gonna
go ahead and do what I did the last time
I checked the box I've been in Cleveland
I'm going somewhere else
after winning in Cleveland Jack no no
the Braun does have to do that because
this Zod has what two three rings so
like you know like if you're in the
pursuit of your first championship and
you join a super team but you know
LeBron I'm sure he's gonna give the
general manager and homers and say hey
we got a recruit and you can never know
you may get some you know big-time
creations I said hey you know what I'll
come join you
is this good for the NBA anything I
don't think it is I mean I'm I'm used to
the area where it's nothing but trials
and tribulations with you know year one
you try to beat a team they beat you
year to each other B team they beat you
to each other et teaching and you
finally learn how to overcome it when I
was growing up kissing's and Pistons and
Lakers with Lakers and the Celtics Bulls
and the Pistons then when I came here
was Lakers in Utah Lakers and spurs and
Lakers important and then you know Miami
and Bowser so I'm used to a music
competition the best competition going
Iman only model trying to beat each
other channel overcome each other now
you're super all the super team stuff a
lot of fan of neither am i neither am i
I'm just wondering if Duran at some
point is going to turn around and say he
wants to try and do it himself and try
and that might be the way that this log
jam gets broken up at some point that
we're assuming it's coming amazing after
he wins and gets gives his monkey off
his back then yeah because you can
always say you know I like I want you
know as a players especially when you're
deemed as a great player you never want
to in your career and not having a
championship you know a lot of guys I
know a lot of guys don't have
championships and they always talk about
I wish I wish I wish so if he wins
tomorrow gets that monkey off his back
then you know he'll kid just his or
mentals and his mind will will loosen up
and and then maybe you could say you
know what you know just like LeBron
didn't mind hey I got the formula I know
what it takes to win I got one now but
go back home
maybe maybe he'll go to Chicago and ride
the coattails of Dwyane Wade who I heard
is got coattails to ride Shaq maybe
that's it
do you think maybe or you know maybe
he's just so you know this feels so good
it's easy because
it's really easy fula gave our days
roaming around on defense and you know I
was just watching shouts having a great
time and you know when one of his
teammates get double he's stepping into
his shot he's not really have to work
hard to get his shot off plus his left
and there's a building maybe I shouldn't
much you can do with a guy like that
anyway that was my way of trying to bait
you into passing Charles Shack he didn't
take that cheese everything all right
with you and Charles our horse yup okay
I just want to make sure because that
would break my heart if there was
something but we're going on between the
two no no we're just you know just I
don't I don't have older brother younger
brother I know I get up my younger
brothers nerves and uh you know we just
station is just do you know when you
respect people you could have any type
of discussion whether it's a nice one
with us a heated discussion loads of
inspectors everything is good
when you come to LA I'd love to have you
in studio you coming out when the
Cowboys are going to come out here maybe
in training your Shack yes yes because I
still oh these are cheerleader belt
somebody somebody's hitting me in the
dress but it was too tight around the
ass area so I just in the fact I'm just
waiting for them to resew to get this
okay do you show all right Shaq madam
all right before we let you go reading
the poll question go ahead and check
what's the best Tom Cruise movie risky
business a few good men Top Gun Jerry
Maguire Rain Man what do you think
oh my go Top Gun and maverick there you
go
you heard he's making another one
apparently hear that yes yes and the
movie is coming out I think of this
weekend that's right look at you Shaq
yes
all right you take care of yourself
thanks for calling for Leland we'll chat
soon
you got it chef so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint
you should download our app with your
thumbprint